good afternoon we
wife good afternoon and welcome to this
webinar organized by the ftth council
Europe I'm Vincent ganier I'll will be
hosting the session I'm the director
general of the ftth council Europe the
the webinar is uh sponsored and and
co-hosted by Sid tracker a member of the
ftth council and is titled A UniFi
vision driving collaboration in
Broadband deployment we will give to to
our um to all participant and delegates
a few more time to join us so bear with
me we will formally start within 30
seconds thank
you
so I think we can we can start Amigo if
you could bring us back to to the
beginning of of the
presentation um I just want to to start
with a few um initial uh con ation
housekeeping item concerning this um
this webinar uh starting with the next
slide with a brief introduction about
the fth council Europe for those who are
not familiar with um with our
association we are a trade Association
created in 2004 with the objective to
promote full fiber Network as the most
futureproof and sustainable Access
Network Technology uh we organize event
like this one a physical event like the
ftth conference and we
regroup 165 uh member now um being
either vendor operator or investor
involved in the ftth deployment in
Europe the next
Slide the this webinar and and is part
of a series of webinar we are proposing
to to our audience on on a monthly basis
um and we hope that it contributes to
providing more insights about this
exciting Market um of um of ftth
deployment in Europe there are a few um
housekeeping item I want to go through
uh on this slide first of all the
webinar is recorded So the replay uh
access to the replay will be shared with
you after the
event um we consider that having given
your consent uh through the U the
process of onboarding for this webinar
you you're okay to receive further
communication to be invited to the next
session we will organize uh in the near
future and concerning uh this session uh
of course you are free and encourage to
ask question to our panel by using uh
the question section in the U control
panel that must appear on your screen so
you cannot uh speak but you can type
your question and we will do our best to
address them at the end of the session
if they are not addressed we will
forward to our panelist and make sure
you have an answer after the
webinar the next slide and I guess I
would directly uh introduce you to both
our speaker and with the topic um the
the objective of this of this session is
quite Broad and is really to cover a
variety of topic like the state of fth
uh coverage in Europe penetration how
the market has evolved and how we
overcome the challenges of modern
deployment and the role of modern
Technologies in Bridging the the global
digital divide with this idea of how
cooperation between the different Market
stakeholders uh influence these topics
so with me uh to to participate in this
session I have amiro garano Amo is Vice
President Telecom EMA at sidetracker and
he will be co-hosting the the convers
session uh with me uh two very
interesting uh representative of um
operators um are also joining us alesio
agostinelli is head of digital Factory
at open fiber open fiber is a an
important uh operator in Italy and
Kristoph zberg is senior vice president
public Affair at DOA glass fazer which
like the name indicates is based in
Germany so thank thank you very much for
participating uh we we are very much
interested in in welcoming your your
insights and your view on these
important
questions and maybe I hand it over
briefly to to Amaro uh for for your your
introduction
Amo I think you're muted sorry uh you
need to unmute
yourself indeed now I should be open
thank you very much Vincent for the
introduction and for uh hosting us in
this uh interesting webinar thank you
alesio and Kristoff to distinguished uh
uh guest and panelist with us today and
of course a warm welcome to all the
attendees that are participating online
as a site tracker we are quite very much
um engaged in the deployment of the
fiber networks because our solution
basically enables service providers
contractors and anyone who is involved
in the delivery chain of fiber Network
deployment in uh accelerating the such
deployment and therefore we believe that
the the theme of collaboration which is
a center to this webinar today is
important to be addressed and I'm very
uh excited to co-host uh this um this
webinar with the ftth council and um the
agenda is
basically going through the state of the
Market uh kindly presented by Vincent he
always give us a very interesting
updates and then we go straight to the
panel discussion and finally as
announced before also a set of Q&A uh
either responded today or afterwards
through
emails Vincent please your state of the
market update so yes a few uh a few
elements just to to set the context of
ftth diplom in Europe and I just want to
say that these slides are very busy
there are much more slides and content
available on the website of the ftth
council so do not hesitate to go there
and download all information you can
find on the on the market um provided by
our Market Panorama in a nutshell um we
passed the threshold of of 62% in Europe
in term of Home Pass in proportion of
the number of household so which means
that we've done uh more than half of the
job but if you look at the bottle from
the other angle there's still uh 40% of
household which have not potentially
access to fiber and if we look at um
that potentiality the bulk of it comes
from Three country UK Germany and Italy
and and two representative at least of
Italy and Germany are with us today so a
lot of what needs to happen in Europe uh
will depend on how things are evolving
in Italy and in Germany but coverage is
one thing what is also important for us
is the level of penetration and Adoption
of fiber and if you go to the next slide
we are sharing information concerning
what we call penetration which is the
number of um subscriber using full fiber
Network to have internet access as
proportion of the number of household
and there you see that the percentages
are are much lower in average only 30%
of um household in Europe are actually
accessing internet via full fber
networks um this is because out of the
60% having potentially access to fiber
only 50% of them only half of them are
actually taking it we call it the tech
up rate which is around 50% and we we
have still a long way to go to increase
that percentage and make sure that the
all the deployment of fiber which taking
place throughout Europe uh is
effectively used by and user businesses
and citizens and here you see for
example that that's a percentage of
subscriber penetration is of 12% in
Italy 7% in Germany those number were at
the end of September 22 so hopefully uh
they have increased quite significantly
and we will release uh the new um Market
result at our conference in March in
Berlin next slide
Amo one of the key
characteristics uh of the the evolution
of um of of the market is that a lot of
the deployment of fiber has been made by
the so-called alternative Operator by
non-incumbent what you can see on this
slide on the left part is that out of
all home past as reported at in
September
2022 um approximately 60% are owned by
alternative operator and there have been
a very important driving force uh to
change the market and to impose fiber as
um as as a growing and as the best
technology uh in their respective Market
there are a variety of business model
among the alternative operator some of
them are whol sale only me and that's
the case of open fiber others are more
integrated like do glass father having
directly acting as an internet service
provider as well as operator of of of
network so there not like there is only
one unique model which works it very
much depends on the strategy of the
operator and on the circumstances of the
market they are active in and more can
be found to analyze these different
model in a report which is available on
our
website and my final slide for the
introduction Amero will just uh give a
view of um our forecast we we are
expecting um or we were expecting in
September 22 the growth of ftth
deployment to continue at approximately
the same Pace both for um coverage Home
Pass and
subscriber um we are projecting in this
number that by
2028 uh the coverage will
will reach something like 80% while the
percentage of subscriber will be
slightly above
50% um we will see the the next result
because we are currently seeing a a
softening of the market in term of
investment so maybe this will influence
a little bit our projection for uh for
the next five years well we will know
more uh when we release the data at the
conference but on the longer term we're
quite confident that there are some very
solid uh Trends in in favor of the
continuation of the investment in favor
of fiber and I guess our two speakers
will U will share their view on that
point uh during the discussion so with
that I'm going go I think I'll
transition to uh to the second part of
um of the
discussion yes indeed I think thank you
so much Vincent for your introduction
now we move into the into the real panel
discussion so uh let's warm up with some
uh uh initial question Vincent maybe you
like to start with and I think that
would be a direct uh continuation of
what I was just presenting uh asking um
both Kristoff and
alesio um you know what
um what is the position of your company
uh in your Market uh um and what is the
perspective you see for for the
evolution uh of the fiber deployment and
of our business maybe starting with with
alesio to to introduce open fiber and
and share a little bit your the
perspective you see for for your
organization in
ity okay uh first of all good evening to
uh everyone and thanks to ftth council
and to invite me as panelist in this uh
uh webinar uh where is open fber open f
is an Italian TCO
operator and the mission of the open F
from the beginning
is the mission of reducing the digital
divide in Italy and as Vince had told
before uh this kind of purpose should be
um reached by uh two factors the the
first one is the coverage of ATP Network
and the second one is the penetration of
the usage in the for the end user in the
in these kind of
networks uh some figures about uh open
fiber up to now open fiber uh has a
footprint of more or less 14 millions of
uh households passed it means that it's
the greater ft pure ftth operator in
uh in Italy in one of the uh most
relevant W sale all operator in uh in
Europe what is our business model our
business model is I will say only uh
business model it means that uh we
guarantee the same services at the same
level of services to all our uh
customers and our customers are the main
retail uh operators in Italy and some
new
operators uh coming from different
sector and Mar that decided in during
the this year to uh Implement new
services in the
Telco um in the TCO sector
and speaking about the
penetration as uh chistopher told that
there is a an issue in Italy and this
issu related to the low penetration with
comparison to the availability of
ftth resources but this is one of the uh
question we deal during this uh uh this
panel okay thank you very very much and
maybe um in parallel Kristoff uh same
question um maybe describe briefly uh
your model and and your perspective for
do Glaser in
Germany yeah thank you Vincent thank you
Amaro same question different answer
maybe um doche glassa is a um also
privately financed company and we roll
out fiber networks in in Rural and
Suburban Germany not only for retail
customers Al for business for
mobile uh operators and also for
wholesale operators so our model is a
bit different uh than the open fiber
model because we combine demand
aggregation and our own retail service
with an Open Access model why is that so
um
the fiber Market in Germany is quite not
yet
mature um so a lot of customers and a
lot of operators areed to the to the old
copper network and to copper copper
Based Services and therefore this model
gives us a certain
Independence of the traditional retail
operators that are still using copper
services to um secure a an sufficient
utilization of our Fi Network from the
from the size we are not as big as as
open fiber we've currently rolled out
around two million households are
commercially secured more than a million
more and have around 600,000 active
customers at the moment so the
penetration is uh high but certainly
needs to be higher especially as in
those areas in suburban and and Rural is
usually just one one passive Network
that is economically sustainable in the
long run so that that for short and
uh back to you thank you Christoph and
Alesia for your answers definitely you
come uh with different perspective but
the challenge is the same so I would
like to ask since you are both coming
from the largest EU countries with the
most work to be done on the ftth network
to reach the objectives of the gigabit
Society by
2025 can you share your perspective on
what are the unique challenges for such
a ambitious ftth expansion plan in your
country alesio first maybe yeah okay
um as you told a great work has to be
done but uh what I have to underline is
that a great work has been already done
because if you if you think about what
was the situation in
2018 the penetration in the the
availability of
ftth network in Italy was uh 22
percentage of the whale the world
territory now we are more or less uh uh
in the percentage of
55 uh um of availability it means that
um uh due to the work of open fiber and
also to the other operators uh in Italy
we
accelerate a lot in this uh in this
moment and as a f can say that we have
some programs with some targets and this
uh availability will grow during the
next uh here what is important from my
point of view from our point of view is
to to focus on on the other hand of the
story that is the penetration because
now the penetration is in
Italy uh less than
20% of the availability of the network
so uh it means that uh with comp
comparison to the
other uh countries in Europe we have uh
an issue that should be H faced and
should be um solved by uh I don't know
if
the if it's a matter of which off for
only a migration but we have to push IM
migration from copper to the
fiber thank you alesio
Kristoff yeah um Italy obviously has
accelerated away from from Germany
because we are we were closer in 20 8 as
you as you settle as you um and that is
due to a couple of factors we still have
an absolute High dynamic in Germany but
we still have
more um connections to covers more than
30 million we still have to go and that
is due to a couple of factors where
where we do or have to do things
differently one is certainly that we
have um High administrative requirements
due to the way we should
deploy uh fiber so it's almost always in
the ground not on poles not using uh uh
aial cables if if necessary if possible
uh we do have issues with uh Market
power right now with duts Telecom so
kind of withholding demand for on third
party networks we have
also issues due to the fact that um we
have a generously financed state aid
program since
2015 we have now still more than 25
billion euros slushing around in
projects looking for capacities so a lot
of things are interfering with an
efficient deployment path that private
operators would like to seek so lot of
challenges still a lot of things to do
but up to now we maintain uh quite a
high rate of deployment in that case so
that's just for short and Kristof to
just to to go back to to the list of
challenges you've just mentioned is
there are there specific challenges to
cover the more uh rural areas in Germany
um is the development going in parallel
equally the same speed for high density
and low density or do you see a
specificity for for the lower density
part of the country
country yeah in we saw a lot of Market
entry in uh since 2017 especially for
the rural and Suburban
areas um also due to the fact that there
was no cable network so you had no
potentially gigabit cable gigabit
enabling Network in those
areas in addition at least what we saw
is that uh the the penetration and the
initial demand were higher in rural
areas despite a demographic that should
use um internet gigabit capable internet
uh Services less we
found most of the audience most of our
citizens willing to to sign up
especially or for those services so
that's something that is that is
unusual um challenges remain that
there's a lot of ground to cover uh to
connect those houses uh to do it
underground nevertheless uh there if you
if there's problems technological Pro
technological progress and also process
progress Sol solving a lot of those
problems if you let industry
innovate thank you and I think um Amero
I think it could be interesting to ask
our audience to to give us some um some
element uh and I will launch the first
poll we have prepared um we you should
normally see it coming uh the question
we're asking you is uh in your opinion
how would you rate the current pace of
Bren deployment in Europe so you have
the choice between ahead of expectations
meeting your expectations or below
expectation
uh I can imagine that most of you are
have high expectations so maybe it be
difficult to uh to meet this um his
ambitious goal but please share your
view I can see that you are um currently
responding um we we have I think half of
you having already responded let's give
you uh a bit more time to to cast your
vote um maybe 20 seconds and then I'll I
will share the result and let uh our
panelist U share their two sents uh
about the outcome of this poll so I
think we we have sort of stabilization
of uh of Voters so let me uh
close uh and share the result I hope you
can see um we have a clear
majority finding the current situation
of investment being below expectation uh
29% meeting expectation and we have a
very few uh representation being super
happy with the with the current
situation of the deployment maybe
um maybe alisio what are your your your
thoughts about um these
results um my point of view is
that even if we accelerated in terms of
uh coverage as we said and even if we
have a
plan the the target of the of the of the
plan H is very challenging it means that
we know it's challenging we know that
it's it's difficult but we work on it
every
day and Christoph are you surprised by
the results um absolutely not but it
gives you maybe also an insight into our
audience I would suspect we have around
30% of engineers in there uh which are
usually very uh people that take in
reality and take in resources and
everything um so for me this result is
uh it showcases
that the let's say the policy Arena has
not done enough to really manage
expectations correctly and have set
goals that
consistently can be uh and will be
missed due to the fact that we have not
taken into account the resources needed
to in the end achieve those goals so
respect I think in in most cases it's uh
not money that is missing but it's uh
either efficiency or the the resource
especially in deployment in question in
the first
place Absol abolutely okay so so I let's
take let's an optimistic view of uh of
these results uh and let's try now to
get into the the real core of our panel
discussion and see how we can as a major
players in this
ecosystem do something
to let's say to remove this um
frustration that the Broadband Market is
below expectation so one point which is
at the center also of this webinar is
about collaboration so let's see how you
two of the major leaders in the great
markets of Italy and Germany how do you
Foster the efficient collaboration
between stakeholders to ensure that
there is a smooth Broadband uh
deployment process that means how you
collaborate internally within your
companies trying to break silos uh how
do you collaborate and communicate with
them with with external parties like
vendor
subcontractors uh and so on I think it's
good if we can share some best practices
so maybe I will ask alesio
first yeah
um as you as you can imagine
collaboration is fundamental for uh
reach targets and objective in a
complex uh project as is the deploy of a
a Broadband Ultra Broadband n working on
the in the wall territory Italian
territory and um if I have to choose to
focus on one aspect H I can uh give you
our experience uh in the collaboration
with the government in term of uh
simplification of bureaucracy because uh
in the rural areas we have more than
6,000 of different municipalities that
we have to to match to phase and which
we have to uh collaborate and if there
is even if there is a
guideline each M municipality can uh um
play a different role along with
different situation local different uh
situation so what we have done uh in
addition to have a continuous
communication
with this municipality and we have a
department that is dedicated only to
have this kind of uh relationship with
them um we had a strong collaboration
with all the
governments uh in Italy and all the
government that
they uh during this uh
ears helps us in New
rules in order to speed up this kind of
project in terms of permits in term in
terms of uh
authorization uh just to give you a a
flavor figure uh our expectation is at
the end of the program in the rural
areas to have more than 100,000 of
authorization requested to the
municipalities this is the uh the amount
of bureaucracies that we have to to
manage thank you alesio so a lot of
focus on communication towards the let's
say the upper layer that means the the
territories and the governments thank
you Kristoff what is um your position
from
Germany I can certainly relate to to
what Ales you said uh regarding the
challenge to communicate especially
electronically or within digital
processes with the uh with all the
different layers of of government and
administration U as you might not know
German has a federal system so we have a
lot of Independence for all the
different actors and you have a lot of
interaction between different layers of
government for one project so it's not
only not only the authorization from the
municipality for the measure itself but
usually it's along a road so you have
Road authorities uh you need to consult
and where you need permission Etc there
has been quite a
longterm project to digitize those
permissions uh and to have at least a u
a first pro pro prototype of such a such
a service to issue and request those
authorizations
electronically that has been lingering
around we have as an industry put some
pressure behind this so now we see a
slow deployment of those systems going
on in several municipalities in Germany
but unless you quoted the number and I
can relate to that uh not all of those
municipalities are requested to
introduce this service but it's
voluntarily it's voluntarily on the um
on the layer of our federal
states um so the federal government can
do almost nothing and then the
municipalities or the counties in
between are still independent too so
that is a big still a big headache
operationally internally and within you
mentioned that the um our
contractors and um external planners Etc
we use fully digitized systems to
communicate with them and and share
information also internally we have a um
relatively strict project blow with
Handover digital Handover points
between different units within doer
glass father to not miss any relevant
project Milestones like oh do I do I
have initiated the
backbone uh is there is there
electricity for the pop whatever needs
to be um thought of in the roll out
process but for us the rooll process
starts with uh analyzing is a commercial
project feasible for which kind of
subset of addresses then I need to
contact the municipality see if there's
any cooperation with them possible if
that's possible I go into demand
aggregation I have to consult with my
wholesale Partners so
each area each subset of address in a
different municipality goes through the
same process and that's uh obviously
includes not only the internal
collaborators but also external ones you
need to have
sales U sales Services included you need
planners you need then the
subcontractors and everything else so
there's a lot going on to to raise the
efficiency and that's I think the the
the message you wanted the positive one
we can still raise a lot of efficiencies
not only with the municipalities but
also internally and externally within
our own project line and that's in
Innovation is constant at
that and and on this point of um of
efficiency for for Process Management
given the complexity of these operation
alio how do you manage your internal
financial plan in term of concrete
processes and tools maybe uh to to
enable you to follow up your your plans
your development plans can you share
that with the with the
audience uh well in the uh in open fiber
we have a classical standard methodology
in order to uh manage uh the the
planning so we have a business plan on
several a and uh these business plan is
in Decline in year by year with a budget
what is important and I think that it's
something that it's very important also
for us is that the financial uh model
and the operating model are aligned it
means that they have the same uh data
model at the basis and in this way we
can uh have quas real time actual on the
um consumption of the of the budget in
this way we have we can uh find if there
are
variation in which is expected in which
is forcasted and so we can act promptly
with the with a feedback we can change
our plan we can change some uh projects
and so on so what is important is from
my point of view maybe from digital
technical point of view is that
financial and operative model should uh
have uh the same data model in this way
the process flows up to down down to up
and you have the possibility to track a
variation and to act promptly this is
what we do in in open five thanks to a
lot of
digitization as Kristoph said before or
we we have we have a relationship by
system with our contractor and
subcontractor so everything
it's um it's in our system and we can uh
make some decision based on
data yes and this is very interesting
especially for us and Sid tracker
however before we move to the next poll
and digitalization questions uh I would
like to ask um a question about how do
you see the role of efficiency evolving
into the deployment process and what are
the best practices that operators could
adopt uh from you that you can share of
course
you so
uh if we uh we talk about
the what is the model open fiber open
the model open fiber it's uh
a model in which a lot of activity are
outsourced it means that from the design
to the network construction we have
contractor and sub subcontractor that
help us in this uh in this activity so
what is important in the relationship
with
them is that they use our system and
they input data in a way that is the
data as a quality and the the data as an
accurancy
because based on the accurancy and the
quality of the data they fill in in our
system we can take uh decision and if
everything Flows In This Way also the
payment towards the contractors it's
quite automatic it's
uh the the best way in order to maintain
a good relationship between uh Us and
Them based on uh data based on facts
that we can uh uh see in our
systems yeah let let me add something on
the on the efficiency usually you strive
for efficiency but sometimes if you're
in a very Dynamic Market with a lot of
Market entry especially in the roll out
competition and efficiency has to climb
into the back seat and the front seat is
taken by speed because you need to
decide or build faster than somebody
else to claim certain certain territory
so that depending on where where how
your Market looks like how your current
competition situation is uh
efficiency uh has to has to wait for its
turn but if you go back to efficiency I
would like to highlight to two things
one is one is
internally
um apart from from what alesio said and
which we would underline anyway um is
that more and more you you need to have
automated system in place to check
quality and progress of your of your
subcontractors for instance if you have
automated otdr measurements Etc to
really see how far and how good their
building and the other thing is I'm
coming back to the the theme alesio
launch with the authorities we have
managed after four years to set together
in Germany a standard for we call it
modern construction methods so methods
that allow us to put networks fiber
networks underground in a more modern
way depending on the requirements that
fiber networks have compared to copper
so A reduced deployment depth
um all the processes I can use from
trenching mini trenching nanot trenching
you name it to
[Music]
um we call it um to either guided or
unguided drilling systems whatever you
you need to give guidance to the
authorities
and either small or or big authorities
uh that have
to decide on your on your um
authorizations to build they need
guidance and up to now they had only
guidance for copper
networks um and that kept you sometimes
from Gaining the the deployment
efficiencies you can get with fiber 2
and we manage now with our new Dean to
capture those efficiencies and we're
bringing them now to the administration
so that might be something that
uh is also valuable for for our
administrations in other member states
um because it raises efficiency and also
sustainability because it uses less fuel
for your
deployment thank you G I think we we can
transition to to the next poll which I
will immediately launch so the question
uh that we as to our audience is what do
you believe is the most
significant challenge in Broadband
deployment
today um well that that's a you know $1
million question first option is
regulatory hurdles um stakeholder
collaboration Workforce or other
resources constraints being the third
option and Reliance on manual processes
um so we are more really to to question
maybe for for operator and contractors
uh on on these topics but I can see that
um yeah the audience is engaging with
the with the poll we have a third of
them having already
responded um yep so I'll give it another
um 30 seconds we we start to to see some
clear Trends among the
respondents
okay let me close the poll and share the
result with
you um so the winner is um tension comes
really from the lack of um Workforce and
and other resources for 55% of the
respondent um the second is the lack of
cooperation between stakeholders and to
a lesser extent our audience perceive
regulatory hurdle as being um something
blocking the the deployment of um of
fiber today uh maybe a very quick word
or maybe you know what I think I'll
leave it and transition to the next
question because we we are a little bit
short of time um and I think it's
probably better to to move to the next
series of question Maro which are
important topic we haven't covered yet
yeah yes indeed Vincent and actually
it's interesting read that um the
Reliance on manual processes was the
least voted uh um question that shows
that to a certain degree
digitalization of processes has uh taken
place widely so I address directly the
question so what role does digitization
play in your various stages like
planning design construction and how can
operators and contractors harness it
optimally
alexio uh so um as I trying to explain
before open five is a data driven
company it means that um everything it's
uh in in the system for each task we
know is who is the ownership what is the
and what is the the
plan in particular for in this stages as
uh planning design construction we as a
a g system that
is
um pni that is a um a g a g system and
uh everything it's uh in there so if you
uh want to plan and you are our
contractor you have to to do it in this
uh system and in this system you also uh
once you have something that is in
designed you have to uh document if
everything it's done during the uh the
deploy of the network so also the people
on field has a direct interface mobile
interface with this uh system and this
system they can put the uh what are the
progressing and the in in in this uh um
in their activity and this is
automatically transform in a b of
quantity and it is
automatically uh uh push to the
accounting system in order to generate
an
invoice a bill uh towards uh uh from
them to to to
us
in order to pay directly from what they
have uh uh registered in in the
system and for us it's uh it's very
important because uh in this is the way
not only for this type of network
creation but also for the other
activities that are the activation def
final user and the maintenance of the
network we have an asset that it's uh
consistent
on top of this G there are some business
process man managers as for example s
tracker and we used to track all the
activities that uh uh we push to the
workforce thank you Alexia for your
Insight for the sake of um let's say
time uh respect for all participants I
may ask maybe the next question that l l
to Kristoff so how are data driven
insights reshaping the Broadband
deployment process in deut glass fer and
can you share some examples or where you
are relying on data uh to improve the
efficiency I sure can and um just let me
come back to to the last question unless
you perfectly described how you do a
modern uh Broadband deployment process
and how to how to design your
relationship especially with the with
the contractors and what is sometimes
forgotten it's very important to have a
data digital proof of
documentation U because you will need
that further on not only to to pay the
contractor but for the decades to come
to operate your network anyway um yeah
data is driving deployment but it's also
driving uh your and our views
on which kind of areas we are able to
deploy in an economically sustainable
way and that's that's why the life
begins with data either public available
data and then data that We Gather By our
specifically constructed cars that
collect Visual and radar 3D data of the
whole area surface
of either roads or areas next to Road
sidewalks Etc of the highest importance
to Garner the idea and Garner
also um
information which kind of deployment
processes you're able to use how many
meters you have to deploy how many
meters lengthwise how many meters to the
houses where you can cross Etc and all
these informations gathered by The Cars
digitally are transferred automatically
to our planning system and therefore
they are able to in a very quick way are
able to deduce how to shape an area to
make it economically sustainable or not
um in addition uh those these surface
informations are also quite of
importance uh if there is
any um dispute with local authorities on
how did the surface look before we came
and how does it look afterwards usually
it looks better but sometimes they think
it look worse um that's something
and where we need more data D insights
at least in Germany is into third party
infrastructures a lot of those
infrastructures are documented in a way
that is not digitally
automatically accessible but sometimes
it's on paper because it's decades old
or the information is there but reality
is different um so those
are um areas where there's still a lot
of progress to be
done than Kristoff so this is a very
good pass for my next question before
the last poll and I'm asking alesio if
you can elaborate on some practical
applications of geospatial integration
and how they speed up your Broadband
roll out have how have they transformed
the deployment
processes okay um what I can mention is
uh uh the last system we implemented in
open fiber that is an application uh
called real City it's a digital twin of
the territory in what we have done in
the work in phase so before the the
designing uh with some surveys with some
particular techniques Bas on uh 360
degree photos and lighter
Technologies uh we import all these data
and with um a close relationship with G
system we can uh open an eye remotely on
the territory when uh
uh our contractor are designing the best
part in order to uh Reach
the the households it means that what
can be done um in a different way is
that if you have to do or to refine the
project you don't need to have
additional uh surveys it means that from
the point of view of efficiency you have
less costs and you you have less time
and uh in addition it's uh a sustainable
way uh to make the same uh work than
before very interesting digital twins
are very uh interesting uh innovation in
our sector all right so Vincent the
launch maybe maybe before we launch the
poll I would like to maybe ask a
question coming from our audience we we
have quite a lot of vendor in the
audience and uh I think the question is
in directly related to what we have
discussing in term of planning but to
what extent this also concerns uh your
procurement the procurement side because
the the question I have is um from a
manufacturer products of of product
supplier of product side um the the
question of that person said that she
feels uh a huge a lot of instability uh
from operators with emphasis on on price
production time lack of preparation
visibility so they're complaining a
little bit about the lack of visibility
for their own planning you know it's
it's a chain uh and to what extent I
guess uh do you also factoring the side
of the procurement in in your in your
planning and how that can be impacted
with everything you've discussed because
many many seem to toh to question that
as well
Christopher
R my my answer is that uh yes we know
that everything should be relied to uh
to the planning also for the uh purchase
office uh uh activity and one of the
project for us on the next year is to
dig digitalize also this step for
example from the need of the network to
organize the contest and for
the uh purchase office in order to uh be
on track in order also to give
visibility to the partner uh of our
program yeah um I can I can mirror that
basically we're not yet the the the car
industry with a very very uh just in
time supply chain um due to the fact
that this industry is quite young and uh
we have been focusing on internal and
then relationships for the with the the
highest priority on on the contractor
side but as alesio said we we need to
think about this blind spot
too okay well I think so the the
question was relevant from from uh our
audience thanks for your for your answer
uh let me launch the the last poll um we
running out of time a little bit but I
think it's still worth having that
interaction with the audience so I'm
launching uh the poll what do you think
uh will be the most critical uh for
achieving the aims of the gigabit
Society vision for
2025 um either improving stakeholder
collaboration funding and capital
planning third option digitizing dated
manual processes or maybe none of the
above um
so um we we are collecting uh
answers um and I won't wait too long to
share the result because I think we have
a a very clear
um level of um of answers which is now
uh starting to to Define itself so um
funding and capital planning seems to be
the the key driver um for for that
answer and then it's more balanced
between the the three other options um
so maybe back to you
um um Amo I think we have two minutes
left maybe we should offer a word of
confusion from from both uh both
panelists yes maybe you can uh alexio
and kis of concluded this very
interesting webinar by drawing your
statements and your conclusions on let's
say what you you think are the biggest
opportunity for for this industry to
achieve the ambitious targets of the
gigabit
Society in Europe
yeah so uh what I can say is that if I
see the mark in terms of requests of
performances in terms of bandwidth in
terms of latency in terms of high
capacity
um the
the our mission to create a Ultra Bron
ftth uh um network is in line with this
expectation so uh the at the end of the
um of this journey
the the result is 12 people using uh our
Network because it's a Futo proof uh
Futo proof Network so H it's the I said
before it's a challenging
uh uh project but uh we like challenges
and uh we are working on
it yeah let me let me add to that open
fiber doche glass F and all the fiber
operators around Europe are building the
most sustainable and future prooof
networks so we figured out how to do
that uh I think the the challenge for
2024 and Beyond is to make sure that the
demand is more adequately addressed not
only from from The Operators themselves
but also from policy and government and
unless you talked about that already we
need to make sure that copper switch off
is non-discriminatory and as fast as
possible we need to make sure that open
access and the usage of those wholesale
and open network network access networks
also by the S&P operators is understood
and
incentivized so do everything for demand
to be able to cut up copper fast not
only helps with the deployment of
broadband but also to achieve the EU
green de goal green deal
gos very much agreed so Vincent I leave
you the the key to the closing of this
event uh from my side I would like to
thank left Council uh alesio and
Kristoff and of course all the attendees
that are online that have expressed
questions thank you thank you well thank
you Amo it's my time also to to to share
a yourself for uh making that even
possible and of course our panelist
again the replay will be shared with the
audience so you'll be able to have
access to to the full session for those
who could not attend live um and also
again uh the ftth council's website
contains a lot of content which enables
to um further um gain Insight on the
different topics which have been
mentioned by alyso and Kristoff on the
state of deployment On Demand on
business model all these data are
available from our website so we
definitely encourage you to to go there
um thank you again for for our audience
thanks for for the panelist we will have
the pleasure to welcome you on another
session uh in the coming week so stay
tuned uh invitation and communication
about these will will come very soon
thank you have a good rest of your day
thank you thank you bye
bye